[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اتساع رقعه المظاهرات في
فرنسا رفضا لتعديل قانون التقاعد زعيم حزب
فرنسا الابيه يتعهد بمواصله الاحتجاجات
ويقول ان رفع سن التقاعد ليس له شرعيه
برلمانيه ويطالب مكرون بالاستماع للجماهير
والحكومه تدعو الاحزاب والقوى السياسيه
الى ادانات العنف
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يتفقدوا دبابات
غربيه تسلمتها بلاده كيف تقول ان الامن
الاوروبي الاطلسي يحدد في ساحه الصراع
ووزير الدفاع الامريكي يحذر من مساعد
روسيه للسيطره على البحر الاسود وموسكو
تتهم برلين بتصعيد انخراطها في الحرب في
حين اعلن الموالون لروسيا السيطره على
المنطقه الصناعيه في
الرئاسه الاسرائيليه تقول ان اولى جولات
التفاوض بشان التعديلات القضائيه بين
الائتلاف الحاكم والمعارضه ستعقد الليله
زعيم المعارضه يعلن الاستعداد للحوار
ويحذر من محاولات نتنياهو للخداع والسفير
الامريكي في اسرائيل يرحب والبيت الابيض
ينفي وجود خطط حاليه لزياره نتنياهو
للولايات المتحده
البنك الدولي يتوقع ان يتباطا نمو
الاقتصاد العالمي على المدى الطويل بمعدل
يبلغ اثنين واثنين من عشره في المئه وذلك
بحلول عام 2030 مرجعا اسباب التباطؤ الى
تداعيات جائحه كورونا وحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا واضطرابات سلاسل الامداد
العالميه الى اللقاء